i am so excited because
there is this major trend that has been
everywhere on social media i am talking
from
gen zers to everyone
else on this planet every age in between
it's called
laundry stripping now this phrase is
something you need to know
because it's sweeping the nation or the
globe
um and here to give us the scoop on this
is the director of
home appliances and cleaning products
lab at get ready for it
the good housekeeping institute i can't
even i feel like
i'm about to meet like a deity um
carolyn forte hello
hi drew how are you
so nice to be with you now will you
please
explain to us carolyn what is
laundry stripping because this is a new
phenomenon
how is it what is it why is it necessary
like you said it's it's just
unbelievable how it's overtaken social
media and the internet
and what it is it's soaking in a hot
water bath
and detergent and some additives clean
clothes the clothes go in
you think are clean but they have
trapped residues inside of them body
soils that haven't been removed
so things like that will then come out
into the wash wall into the water
it gets this murky kind of gray black
look to it oh it does it makes a perfect
um instagram or tic toc picture to show
how dirty your clean clothes really are
that's why
it's taken off as it has if i said i was
hot under the collar i'd be making the
understatement of my life
take me through this carolyn teach me
how to laundry strip
we're gonna do it one step at a time now
first thing you do is most people do it
in their bathtub so you'd fill the
bathtub
with hot water you've got a base in
there so
um but you could do it in a basin you
could do it in a sink okay so you got
your hot water
you ready
okay i do and now what you're gonna do
is you're gonna pour in
some borax quarter cup of borax
you're gonna add a quarter cup of
washing soda
yeah you will now borax and washing soda
are products that you can use in your
laundry usually and for cleaning around
the house so
um it's not unusual to put them in here
and then you're going to add your
laundry detergent a half a cup
right so you're gonna stir it around
there you go oh that's nice
i i'm very really invested in this so
now you can put your items in okay so
just drop them in
um we recommend if you're going to do
colors
make sure that they are color fast and
won't shade because the hot water can
fade certain colors yeah i can mind you
don't want to do this on delicate
fabrics certainly
would damage them but if you're going to
do colors
do colors together if you're going to do
whites which is really what we recommend
it for if you're going to do it at all
do those separately as well so now you
you let you're going to let that soak
and that needs to soak about four or
five hours
so until the water cools off in fact we
have done that
carolyn yes we thought ahead all right
ready okay here we go and a one two wow
oh my gosh look at that water look at
this
i mean the wa it is like purpley blue
now once you're done with that you have
to take those clothes out put them in
your washing machine
rinse them and then put them in the
dryer so you know you're not done yet
once it's in
in the finished after it's four hours in
the tub you still have some
some schlepping to do to take your
laundry to the washing machine to rinse
it out but
it's important to keep in mind that if
you you don't want to go through this
process
you shouldn't have to just make sure you
use a good detergent
a good deep cleaning detergent don't
overload your washing machine because
that will contribute to residues
if clothes can't move around and tumble
they're not going to get clean
you want to measure your detergent and
you've got to sort like we talked about
already sorting is important and finally
you can always add some borax or
washing soda right in with your
detergent and it'll do the same job
carolyn so nice to meet you
carolyn carolyn carolyn uh
you have my dream job you are
a dream for me to meet um it has been an
honor and a pleasure i have literally
been looking forward to this segment all
week
and um i just want to thank you so much
and guess what
speaking of linens and laundry all of
our vfs are getting
a bamboo bath towel set and classic
bamboo sheet set from
kara aloha i know
and cara aloha has been a company that
has been kind enough to gift
our vffs in the past and we love working
with them so thank you
and carolyn ah
my pleasure maybe to be here thank you
thank you so much
please have um think of me when you're
in the good housekeeping
um lab i will but when we go back you'll
have to come visit
i'd love to show you our lab
[Applause]
when we're back
thank you carolyn
you